politics is the last place where we're
supposed to be satisfied with the choice
between Brandi and Brandi I am Nikhil SP
for recent TV today we're talking with
John Avlon the author of the new book
wingnuts how the lunatic fringe is
hijacking America define a wing nut and
give us an example there's a right wing
not in a left wing not give us a so-so
wing nut is someone on the far right
wing or far left wing in the political
spectrum these are the professional
partisans the unhinged activists the you
know paranoid conspiracy theorists the
people who are always trying to unite us
rather than divide us and and there have
been many of them throughout our history
I mean you know in politics today you've
got two congressmen who are two of my
favorite wing nuts
I eat least favorite people Alan Grayson
on the left and Michelle Bachman on the
right in media you know certainly Glenn
Beck and Keith Olbermann have a lot of a
lot of parallels and I always I mean
describe when you say they're lunatic
fringe what puts them over the edge from
recent discussion well usually it's not
actually the figures themselves it's the
fact that they're using incitement and
the effects of that I mean you know hate
is a cheap and easy recruiting tool but
it can be murder on a democracy and that
is what we're starting to see now we're
starting to see that the dialogue from
these folks the way it trickles down
we're playing with dangerous stuff so
for example Rush Limbaugh says on radio
one week you know if al Qaeda wants to
destroy America they better hurry
because if Barack Obama's beating them
to it and then ten days later it's an
assign in a protest and it's the
demonization of people who disagree with
you it's the it's the elevation sort of
pumping up hate in the service of hyper
partisanship that I think is really in
the process of taking us off the rails
and I just think we need to call it out
and confront it tell you know how is
that different than politics as usual in
America you know in the 19th century
Abraham Lincoln was shown as a baboon or
a monkey or whatever you know Little
Orphan Annie used to attack the Harold
gray the creator of Little Orphan Annie
attacked FDR all the time what's what's
different and what's new well I think I
think the reason you know we've always
had extremes in our politics we're never
going to change human nature we
shouldn't bother to
try the the difference is is that the
wingnuts are more powerful than ever
before and I think there are three
reasons for that one the parties are
more polarized than ever before so the
power has moved from the center to the
extremes second all we got the rise of
partisan media you know yeah you had
father Coughlin with a radio show in the
past and all that but now you've got
people with national reach really in
many cases repeating stuff that you know
John Birch Society claims but reaching
millions of people and actually instead
of getting talking points from the
parties all of a sudden it's reversed
you know that the talking points are
actually coming from the talk radio host
to the TV host and going to the parties
themselves and the third thing is the
internet you know the Internet can be an
incubator for extremism it becomes a way
for radicalization you get a bunch of
people who think alike all talking to
each other and there becomes an impulse
to try to drum anybody out who disagrees
this is this sort of you know the hunt
for heretics we see in the parties you
know the hunting for rhinos in the
Republican Party and Donna's the
Democratic Party you know this this gets
exacerbated to the point where it starts
looking and feeling not a little like a
cult you you talk about the push to the
extremes in the political process at the
same time that actually a large and
growing group of people pretty much
agree on things right and we agree on a
lot of social issues and a lot of
general political issues but we are that
is exactly right we are artificially
divided this country we have been sold a
totally dumbed down version of American
politics that divides everything in the
red states and blue states far left
versus far right and it's a lie it is a
fraud it is not actually the way we are
it's not the way we vote you know
independents are the largest and
fastest-growing segment the electorate
not Democrats not Republicans and
independents if you look at them very
closely you know professional partisans
here in watching to dismiss him and say
oh there's nothing really happening here
don't look behind that curtain but what
you see is that independence tend to be
fiscally conservative and socially
liberal to libertarian there's very
clearly and they are sick and pissed off
about the hyper partisanship in
Washington they feel like our politics
have been hijacked by people who are
screaming at them all the time from both
sides and so there is a mainstream it is
a generational divide two independents
are the youngest and fastest-growing
segment of the electorate so where do if
you're an independent and if you're not
a wingnut where do you go to express
yourself politically in a system you
know that is always going to be run by
two parties well I don't think it's
always gonna be run by two parties I
think that the first thing we need to do
is that
they start declare our independence and
standing up we are a generation that's
grown up with a multiplicity of choice
and everything politics is the last
place where we're supposed to be
satisfied with the choice between brand
a and brand B it doesn't fit the way we
live it doesn't fit the way we think the
parties are trying to prop up they're
playing defense in effect there with
gerrymandering other things trying to
hold on to power ever they can
fundamentally they are playing by
Industrial Age rules they have not woken
up the information so they're like the
record companies yes right in politics
who are a couple of politicians who you
think get it and push or give a hint of
what's coming down the pike John McCain
before he won the nomination you know
spoke for a lot of independence I think
you know certainly Barack Obama I think
generationally understands the split I
mean he's been sort of a bridge builder
his whole life right his whole pitch was
and he's the first Gen X president right
his grandparents voted for Nixon his mom
was you know a 1960s hippie that that he
sort of understood that the whole left
versus right black versus white and
analysis of American politics was
[ __ ] and that he could embody that
was his sales pitch that he could embody
and bridge those divides and I think
that is a generational Road split I
think the problem we've seen is is that
he's alleged you know his background is
as a legislator not as an executive and
he's had a very hard time changing the
culture well is there anything in him
though for instance that would suggest
that he cares at all about economic
freedom or has a knowledge of the
private sector as the engine of growth
no and this is the most credible hit on
the Obama administration and you hear
this more and more and more is that
there's no one with any private sector
experience and you have that you know
the Liberal House leadership in
particular I think they look at the way
he campaigned and they just they
misinterpret US election as a liberal
ideological mandate and then they took
the fiscal crisis and they said we get
to you know we have unified control
we're going to do Keynesian spending and
and you know get every wish list project
we got they didn't understand that the
American people rejected Cain's ian's
begins in the long time ago and
independents have been a deficit Hawk
since at least Ross Perot we are angry
at overspending we are you know
concerned about the deficit the
generational theft that occurs in fact
that China owns our debt these are not
incidental geostrategic problems so they
I think are from a 1970s and 80s
big-city liberal culture that has an
endless appetite for bit for
dollars and that's where the disconnect
happened when those folks asserted
control the Obama administration's
agenda independent started abandoning
them and then and and so I think you
know the the Harlan Tea Party movement
its libertarian is a fiscal conservative
protest the problems come in when you
get the Obama derangement syndrome baked
in and that's when it goes you know so
is the Tea Party you know the the kind
of avatar of new independent people in
America or is it never quickly going
into wingnut territory III think that in
the Tea Party movement is a conservative
populist movement I think there's a lot
of common ground with independence and
many libertarians on anger about
overspending about deficit about debt
but again the problem is is this Obama
derangement syndrome is getting baked in
the cake and you know when you've got
people calling the president you know
comparing him to Hitler a communist you
know the Antichrist I mean one of the
sections in my book is called how Hitler
how Obama became Hitler a communist and
the Antichrist where it actually looks
at the progress of that rumor and looks
who pumped it up how it took root
because it has got embedded in some
folks Minds that is fundamentally
unhealthy even for Laura Christian yes
no and you know and so that that should
just be a warning shot you know we've
seen a lot of these attacks before the
Birch Society before they were you know
they just co-sponsored CPAC somehow the
John Birch decide his back I thought we
dealt with him 50 years ago when they
said that President Eisenhower was a
communist agent but these ideas you know
keep getting recycled and they're
getting recycled at a higher level than
ever before and I think that's why it's
so important to call out the extremes on
both sides because that's the other
problem is you know if folks get in a
position where they only criticize the
extremes on one side and then they get
end up getting sucked into being part of
the problem so part of my hope is but we
standing up to the extremes on both
sides we can restore some sanity and
perspective to the politics here because
it's not just a generational grudge
match between the baby boomers talk a
little bit about the overlap between
independence and libertarians this is
hugely important and not very well
understood when we talk when you look at
independence there in between the
Democratic and Republican parties but
there are closer to Republicans on
economic issues and closer to Democrats
on social issues what that means
functionally is a centrosome that is
totally aligned with many libertarian
principles these are folks who
understand fiscal conservatism but also
individual freedom when you combine
physical conservatism and social
liberalism us actually get a libertarian
so I think that libertarian is actually
the new center I think that is the
rising center in American politics when
you look at independence they are
reflecting to a large extent a
libertarian perspective maybe now
detriment doctrinaire who are those
people that embody that in politics now
I think it's actually a grassroots
movement I don't think the leadership is
reflecting where the American people are
and that's one of the problems that's
one of the disconnects we've got our
politics do not reflect where the
American people are especially young
Americans you know we we've 44 percent
of Americans born after 1977 are
independent they reflect a libertarian
mindset in many cases they do not buy
into the whole hyperpolarized politics
and that's why our politics are getting
hijacked they're trying to resist this
rising tide but so it's really up to us
to reflect that change and put forward a
new generation of leaders that's
consistent about this that because you
know the politics are actually much more
consistent than the ideological
straightjacket that the far left and the
far right tries to put the Democratic
Republican Party I want to thank John
Avila an author of wingnuts how the
lunatic fringe is hijacking America for
talking to reason TV today I'm Nick
Gillespie
you